so i'm going to tell you a story that i
haven't really ever shared before when i
was young i remember watching
ahmed didat and other preachers and
they were just mesmerizing they had a
deep impact on me with the absence of a
physical father figure in the house the
tao became the replacement father figure
my love for dawa
and my school experience actually led me
to suffer from a lot of doubts i
remember some of my teachers at in the
school as well were
slightly new atheists trying to push
that kind of world view
and these kinds of things would actually
have an impact on me i came frustrated
because i didn't have the intellectual
tools to deal with
all the doubts this actually all started
to have a spiritual effect on me that's
why when i started
learning classical arabic with my mom
who is an arabic teacher this was the
key really in accessing the tools
not only deal with the doubts but share
islam effectively a key milestone in
dealing with my doubts was
during ramadan when i was about 17 years
old i'm from alexandria
egypt we went and it was a beautiful
kind of ramadan experience we had and i
remember i made dua
when i was in sujud in that ramadan
experience and i said
may allah test me with anything except
for doubts i never want to be tested
with doubts ever again and
subhanallah sometime after that that was
it that
you know it was done really
i'm no when i'm actually confronted with
these doubts now all these kinds of
misconceptions
actually raises me in iman alhamdulillah
my path towards dawa has now
you could say accelerated every decision
i made
in every step i took i would always
think of ways i could benefit the tower
so even if i'm in education et cetera i
would be thinking about that i believe
that this has to do actually with my
mother and we all know the power of a
mother's diet
my mom tells me that she wasn't getting
pregnant for about seven years so she
went to amber one time and while she was
drinking zem zam she made diet to have a
son who
would be a diet and she mentioned so
many things in the dui so then after
that i was born i credit everything
actually to my mother's dwara and her
endurance support throughout these years
because she's my inspiration and
actually my role model i would not be
the person i am today without her
may allah bless her when i got married i
actually got married when i was 20 years
old and i was involved in the daoa but i
needed to be able to support my family
so i wanted to
get into teaching so i considered this
as an occupation because of my dowel
interest though i
already had the kind of the channel at
the same time
many of you may remember i attended a
right-wing protest at that time with
tommy robinson in the
free freedom protest where you call it
and unfortunately after that i lost my
job and this was like two or three weeks
before i would actually get the qts
i didn't get the teacher's license um
and all of those
years while i was trying to get the
teacher's license and all the getting to
teaching was gone in a moment after that
though
i was tutoring and freelancing and kind
of working in different kind of things
for scraps it was a matter of survival
at this point i started to take the dao
even more seriously so i've done another
master's
degree in islamic studies and another
one
in applied theology i realized that
things like philosophy of religion which
i spent a lot of time focusing on
are needed in the tower like for example
improving god's existence and
the arguments for god's existence
etcetera theodicy all these things
so alhamdulillah after that and i
applied for the phd program
in the philosophy of religion to further
my work and that's why there is muhammad
hijab
and not muhammad hijab the history
teaching i feel i understand why allah
made me lose
out on being a history teacher he did so
to guide me to teaching people about
islam what's amazing about my story is
that i started with doubts
and now i'm trying to answer the doubts
so subhanallah how
allah has blessed me to be part of the
sapience institute team which is this
institute which we share
and defend islam academically and
intellectually and empower and develop
others to do the same in under one year
we've developed and trained over 6 000
people to intellectually share and
defend islam delivered over 33 in-depth
webinars
delivered 10 courses in seven hours
published three books
launched a thoughts and produced 30
videos launched
our lighthouse mentoring service which
is a one-on-one service for people that
like ex-muslims and people that have
doubts where we actually go through
their doubts and much more all for free
if this story has inspired you in some
way please support
this noble work and start your monthly
donation
today the link will be found in the
description box
you